so today we are going to talk about type
systems and I'm really excited about
this because I've I've had a couple
attempts at getting this topic ready
it's such a deep topic and you can go
all kinds of different directions with
it but I think let's kind of see where
we go today but this is one that I put a
lot of time into the kind of researching
and figuring out the best way to talk
about it but type systems are pretty
cool whenever I first started
programming I learned C++ and so types
to me at that time were you know you're
working with integers you're working
with strings very primitive types you're
working with pointers and memory
structures and then later got in like
c-sharp dotnet Java you're working with
objects and class types and really that
was kind of the world of the type system
at that point you have you know design
patterns which kind of leverage some of
the benefits of the type system whenever
I got into functional programming though
it was when it really opened up my mind
to how sophisticated type systems can be
so I started programming in Scala
several years ago and I was like wow
there's a lot to learn about types that
I didn't know before so languages have
come a long way since and so today I
would like to do kind of a high-level
survey of what is a type system and
we're going to look at different type
systems that are out there and then
slide into how does functional
programming impact the design of a type
system so I'm gonna do start out by
reading three quotes I'm gonna do
something that you're not supposed to do
in a live presentation and read from the
slide okay I'm gonna read three quotes
about type systems but they give us
different facets about what a type
system is and I think they're important
to understand the different facets so
first quotes a set of rules that assigns
a property called
a type to the various constructs of a
computer program such as variables
expressions functions or modules these
types formalize and force the otherwise
implicit categories the programmer uses
for algebraic data types data structures
or other components okay so I heard
variables functions are module
all right so I think if most of us in
here are comfortable with programming
languages and general programming
languages we can kind of understand
what's going on here right okay now this
next one a type system is a tractable
syntactic method for proving the absence
of certain behaviors by classifying
phrases according to the kinds of values
they computes oh yeah that one's a
little deeper all right this one comes
from a foundational book based on type
theory called types and programming
languages in fact if you're interested
in getting into type theory that book is
available online it's considered kind of
a one of the de facto defining books
about it and this is where mathematics
and logic systems begin to blend with
computer systems so it sounds very much
like we're describing a proof here so if
your common with mathematical proof the
idea that a type system can correlate
with mathematical proofs and so you can
write programs that are therefore
provable all right so that's the angle
that this is taking and then lastly this
isn't necessarily a definition of a type
system but it describes what is
important for a type system intuitively
speaking you want your type system to
induce a system of logic that is
consistent that is doesn't allow false
theorems to be proven the more
inconsistent the system of logic induced
by the type system is the less useful
the type system is is a proof of
correctness of the code in other words
the more strict sophisticated type
system you have the more consistent
output you're going to get and then the
opposite is true as well so I think this
this quote is one of the reasons we
should study type systems and understand
and utilize the type systems whenever we
build things and my first talk a long
time ago I talked about how we as
software developers are builders right
we're not syntactic experts we are
builders we're building things and so
the more we understand about
how to build things and build things
better the better we will be at our
profession inter and what we do so what
are the goals of a type system some of
these are pretty obvious so I want to
check for bad behavior we want to do
that as early as possible so that we
learn about the problems in our program
at the time of writing the program and
not having our users do it we want to
enable abstractions so I don't want to
have to talk to the computer and ones
and zeros I would like to use integers
and strings
I'd like to use objects I would like to
use expressions alright so the type
system enables me to do that and also it
provides documentation the more
sophisticated type system you have the
more documented your code is going to be
because the code is going to represent
the truth right when you add code
comments and that's your primary mode of
documentation it's easy for that to
drift over time or be inconsistent maybe
the the code comments captured the
developer's perspective of what's going
on but it may not really be what's
happening so a good type system also
helps you self document your code better
okay question at all what are some of
the things that we do to evaluate if
we're going to use a programming
language I'm going to open this up to
the floor what are some ideas when
you're evaluating to use a particular
programming language what are the some
of the things that you look for
community very good what else
flexibility okay so it solves the type
of problem we're trying to solve speed
okay so how approachable is it okay so
the the availability of expert
developers people that know the language
and are going to precise it mm-hmm
yeah these this is the list I came up
with the very first thing you're
probably going to do is you're going to
evaluate the domain of the language
alright does this is this a language
that solves the problems I'm trying to
solve if I'm gonna write a web page or
client-facing logic I'm probably not
going to choose C++ alright people do
that but you're probably not gonna
choose that as your first choice you're
probably going to choose from a language
in the JavaScript family because that is
the domain that that language was
created for if I'm going to do intensive
data processing and I'm going to use a
lot of asynchronous operations I'm
probably not gonna choose JavaScript
okay because that's not the domain that
that language was written for so the
first thing you're probably going to
look at is the domain that the language
fits in the second thing is community so
whenever I got the domain and I got a
family of languages we all know there's
those languages that are experimental
they're really cool-looking but there's
five guys in a garage that use that
language and maintain it right so you're
gonna probably choose a language that
has a large community a lot of experts
they're gonna blog about it they're
gonna you know put a lot of
documentation out there okay and I'm
gonna argue this third point is type
system okay we might favor certain
syntax but really it's the type system
next that we're gonna care about what
does the language offer us as building
tools if you get anything from this talk
today this is the one thing I want you
to get the more you use your type system
the more it works for you all right
if you use your type system primitively
don't expect anything beyond primitive
behavior from your type system so if you
use rich types and rich type system
features to describe your domain then
you'll find your type system actually
enforcing your dumb
and I think that's very important okay
so I'm gonna set a few expectations here
what we're gonna we're gonna do we're
only going to scratch the surface and
I'm not going to get super deep in the
type theory we're gonna we're gonna
bounce on it but we're not gonna go
super deep here okay there is a lot when
you start studying types that you can go
into there are books and books there are
PhDs that get into this so we're just
going to scratch the surface and we're
gonna make it relevant to software
development also I am a scholar
developer I am comfortable in Scala so
any code you see is gonna be in Scala
however I am NOT going to use anything
that is outside of the standard library
and I'm not gonna use anything that is
you know easy to understand and also I'm
not gonna do anything that's specific to
Scala so what I'm saying in Scala today
is also applicable in Haskell F sharp
and a lot of the other languages we use
okay so I'm gonna keep this very as
language agnostic as possible but I got
to be able to speak in something all
right so we're gonna start today with
fundamentals all right so just the
basics most basic type systems support
these three things type safety static
first dynamic type checking and type
inference when we're talking about type
safety a safe language is one that
protects itself from its own
abstractions all right so let's think
about safe verse unsafe behaviors C++
I'm gonna pick on it for a minute
very unsafe language all right and C++ I
can dereference null pointers I can
access arrays out of bounds I can return
memory locations out of a function that
don't belong to the scope of the
function I can use uninitialized
variables I can also at will cast
between and reinterprets memory
addresses into different data types
right that is very dangerous behavior in
fact it's not going to be something
caught at compile time and at runtime
you're not going to get an exception
it's going to crash your program or
worse yet open you up to exploits
all right the last one is me poking at
JavaScript it doesn't check parameter
list so when you get to a function you
have no idea what was passed into that
function or how many parameters right so
these are unsafe behaviors and on the
other side safe behaviors are languages
that are going to catch exceptions we're
going to disallow uninitialized
variables at compile time we're gonna
check parameter list we're gonna check
types okay those are safe operations now
when we are evaluating a language it's
not a binary characteristic right it's
not that this language is unsafe and
that this language is safe there are
aspects of the language that favor
safety all right so it's kind of a lot
of shades of grey you know memory safety
abstraction safety runtime safety all
right this one static versus dynamic
type checking static type checking we
verify the program is safe before
execution dynamic we're gonna do it at
execution time all right
so question to the audience why do we
get in so many religious arguments about
static versus dynamic checking I'm
trying to be a troll don't swing for it
all right more seriously pros and cons
of static first dynamic type checking
this is a serious question
exactly exactly yeah so we're gonna
pretty much this Aaron's sum that up
very well so essentially with static
type checking you're going to get very
early feedback if there's problems in
your code you're going to get more
optimizable code because less guesswork
has to be done at runtime but you're
gonna have to annotate your code a lot
more and that test compile cycle is
going to be a little bit longer now
dynamic type checking on the other hand
it's very quick on your feet off the
cuff you can do a lot of different type
introspection you get duck typing if it
looks like this you can change things at
runtime it's fantastic for prototyping
but you're also gonna have to write a
lot more unit tests to do things that a
statically typed type system would check
for normally right you don't want to be
at runtime and not have any unit tests
and turns out you're getting crazy types
passed around everywhere they're really
for different kinds of applications you
got to think about that here are just
some languages that are static versus
dynamic I think most of us are probably
familiar with a lot of these something
I'll spend too much time here okay this
last one I threw in just because I don't
feel like it'd be complete if I didn't
mention it strong versus weak typing the
community generally says this is a very
bad description because it's very
unclear what it means but essentially my
ability to reinterpret a type of the
variable at runtime
all right so in a static strongly typed
language I'm not going to want to say
assign a variable value I can't change
the type of that value whereas like if
I'm in C++ I can't change it I can
reinterpret cast that memory address
into something else or I can use unions
or other things that let me do that
JavaScript whatever whatever whatever
all right yeah so so you get the idea
okay so again shades of grey it's kind
of all over the place and languages
cover these in different areas a little
bit differently
okay then last one of the basics I want
to talk about is type inference this is
a benefit of statically type systems
where I don't have to annotate all my
types explicitly but they can be
inferred based on what's on the right
okay so down on the left you can see I
put types at the end of my variables and
on the right I didn't put any types but
the compiler is able to figure out what
that is okay that is still a feature of
static typing language a lot of people
confuse that with dynamic typing it's
different this is static typing still
it's done prior to execution but it's
just the the compilers being super-smart
and figuring out what I got the biggest
benefit of this is and we as functional
programmers know this is that whenever
you're doing functional programming you
don't have to tell the computer how to
do every little step of something so for
instance when I'm in an imperative
programming language and I'm doing a
loop I have to describe exactly how that
loop is going to work all right I have
to have a counter I have to have an
increment and I've got to kind of follow
through there in functional programming
we like expressions so what is it that I
want done and I'm gonna let the compiler
figure out how to build that okay type
inference is a nice advanced feature
that lets us get there okay and then one
last thing about this type driven
development whenever you have a really
powerful type system you can write
programs with just the types okay the
functions and the type signatures at
osburgh where I work whenever we write a
new micro service it's not uncommon for
us just to write functions and types the
entire micro service before we provide
any implementation at all and then once
it compiles and we understand that the
overall structure of the code looks good
then we'll fill in the itty gritty
details about how those functions are
going to be accomplished but because
we're using a strict programming
language I know that if I have that
input mapped to and outputs that
whenever it compiles it's probably going
to work all right so that's type driven
development okay how we doing so far
all right that's that's just kind of the
basics even general-purpose programming
languages are going to support that
probably nothing really groundbreaking
there all right so let's let's go down a
layer deeper okay and to richer features
of the modern type system
okay now this one a lot of us are
probably already familiar with but
functions as types these are called
higher-order functions and what a
higher-order function means is that I
can pass a function into another
function as an argument or I can return
a function from another function okay as
the return type so in this example I
have I'm assigning to a variable a
function
alright used in this way this is an
anonymous function but I'm saying Y is
going to be an integer and that is going
to yield another integer it's going to
yield Y plus 100 so I can call X passing
in 50 and I'm gonna get 150 so integer
to integer alright in this example I'm
going to define a function where in the
formatter position it's going to take
another function as its input so I'm
going to pass in a sequence of integers
and then I am going to pass in a
formatter that's going to take an injury
and return a string and that whole
function returns a string so it's going
to loop through that list of integers
and it's going to run it through that
formatter to generate strings and then
concatenate that all together so you can
see I'm going to define F as taking an
integer and then I'm going to call that
format function and I'm just going to
pass F right into it and I'm gonna get
that result at the bottom all right so
that's higher-order functions a lot this
is kind of the rage these days of
programming languages because a lot of
programming languages that did not start
with higher-order functions are starting
to adopt them now so you know c-sharp
supports these Java is beginning to
support these most of the functional
programming languages already support
this javascript supports this you get
the idea
this is an example using a technique
called partial function application
occurring now this is syntax that's a
little bit more specific to Scala but
Haskell does this very well fact this is
the only way you pass multiple
parameters in Haskell but essentially
what I'm doing is I'm gonna have two
parameter lists and I can apply the
parameter list at different points of
execution so I can start out and I can
provide the prefix string to my Greek
function which I'm doing there in the
hello greets kind of in the middle and
then later on I can apply the second
parameter list okay that process is
called curring and then so there I have
hello greets and I'm going to call it
once with Jordan I'm gonna call it again
with Alex and I get two different
results at the bottom there so it's just
late applying parameters to a function
alright switching gears
so the question is yeah what is the
benefit of curring there's different
benefits so if you're going to language
like Haskell for instance that's just
kind of the way that you do it right so
all of your functions are going to take
one parameter and you essentially every
time you invoke it you're gonna get
another function that expects the next
parameter until you get the result when
you study category theory that is
actually very natural with how category
theory handles mappings from categories
but more pragmatically it is kind of a
way of doing dependency injection for
your functions if you want to think
about it that way
so let's take the example where you want
to make a call to a database and you
want to pass in something that's going
to like a parameter that's going to
query the database on a filter you might
want to pass in the connection string of
that database before you you do your
call because you want to do injection on
your configuration but you don't want to
have to do that all the way down at the
point that's needed so what you can do
is you can pass in like that config type
early on in your program and that's
going to give you a function that's
going to talk to the database that
already has that baked into it so then
later on in your code you can call it
with the filter value and it's already
got that other one in place and so then
it'll run so it kind of helps you from
having like these really long parameter
lists you can kind of build it up over
time that's that's one example there's
there several others but that's kind of
like a immediate practical one all right
so let's talk about conditional so if
you guys ever seen this you know people
online talking about how if statements
are evil does anybody take a bat as to
why if statements are are considered not
great you gotta cover all the cases yeah
so exactly Zac first a lot of times they
don't return a value so you're not going
to guarantee the output from that
conditional body Dylan
exactly so for testing you have a lot of
different conditions you got to check
for and so that's just more things you
have to test in your code every single
branch you got to take any others yeah
that's pretty good if if conditions are
completely loose right you know you can
say if some predicates else if some
other predicates else has some other
predicates but those predicates don't
have to be related to each other right
you can have something that logically
makes sense in the first predicate and
then the second check you know maybe it
makes sense or maybe it doesn't you know
there's no enforcement by the type
system there so it would be really nice
if we add native support for controlling
that from our type system so there is
something that we have called algebraic
data types that is one solution to this
now my Haskell people are gonna say well
wait a minute algebraic data types are
more than that that's true so let's kind
of break this down an algebraic data
type is a variant type that supports sum
and product algebras all right and it's
going to let us do pattern matching on
that so what I mean is there's two
things an algebraic data type let's this
represents some meaning I can have an A
or a B but not both and then there's the
product which says I can have a and B
together all right now that's the
conceptual definition of an algebraic
data type so let's break that down a
minute products algebra is look like
this this is stuff we know a tuple is an
algebraic data type of a product algebra
in other words I have two types that
come together so in that first case I
have an int and a boolean they come
together as a package deal and then the
range of tuples i can support is all of
the possible values for an integer
combined with all the possible values of
a boolean okay classes it's the same
thing at the bottom i'm packaging
together two different data types with
that class in that class the range of
supported values is going to be whatever
I can
put an integer and whatever permutation
I can put into a string which is a lot
wider all right here's the more
interesting one though some types a or B
but not both so if you have been in
functional programming at all or you've
seen any of our other talks here we
talked about like the option type and
you'll remember the option type is like
a it's like a base class and usually you
have a sum or a none we're talking about
the same type and I can use them
interchangeably but the specialized
version means two different things I got
either this or this but not both at the
same time that's also true with the
either-or sometimes called a disjunction
I got a right or a left but not both
or like a tri type this is more specific
to Scala I have a success or a failure
all right so that's that's what an ADT
lets you do but the really cool thing
about ATT's is you can do pattern
matching on them so instead of writing a
bunch of if-else statements you can
pattern match on all the combinations
and the type system will enforce if
you've covered all the cases and if you
haven't covered all the cases you'll get
a compiler warning all right so you can
see in this example we have an error as
the subtype or I'm sorry the super type
and then you got argument parser and
runtime error that all derive from that
each of those takes slightly different
shapes and their constructor down at the
bottom I have an argument error instance
and then I can do a pattern match I can
say okay if that thing is an argument
error then handle it that way if it's a
parse error handle it this way if it's a
runtime error handle it this way and if
I leave off any of the cases I'm gonna
get a compiler warning that's gonna say
hey you're you're forgetting something
you need to go fill that in because we
don't know what's gonna happen when we
get that match okay any questions there
Dylan yes so if you're in Scala the
sealed keyword is essentially the thing
that's going to define that all of these
types are together and it can't be
further modified outside of that scope
in other words you're not gonna have a
code file it's going to add in other
extensions to it
that are going to make your match
statements break that's more of a
scholarism
if you're familiar with C++ that might
resemble an enum type but enews those
are really just fancy integers under the
hood the type systems aren't going to do
a whole lot for you there these are a
lot more sophisticated because it's
actually the shape of the type itself
all right polymorphism anybody want to
guess how many types of polymorphism are
there sure all right yeah okay
so there's three kind of main types of
polymorphism we talked about so most of
us are probably familiar with what we
call subtype polymorphism and parametric
polymorphism so what that allows you to
do is you have like a classic examples
when you're using object-oriented
inheritance you've got a base type so
let's say we've got a shape type and you
got specialized versions of that shape
triangle square circles and then each of
those can give you like an area right
and so I don't care what specific type I
have I can call dot area and I can get
back whatever whatever that specialized
type returns me that's polymorphism and
a subtype level let's look at the other
two a little bit okay well I kind of
already spilled the beans on that one
well actually let's listen to find this
why do we use polymorphism
mm-hmm so it's gonna unify a lot of
different it's an abstract over
behaviors exactly so I can have a bunch
of specialized types but they all be
unified and treated as the same based on
common behaviors between them mm-hmm
okay so let's look at parametric
polymorphism well that's a $50 word okay
this is very similar if you use c-sharp
or Java this should be very familiar to
you okay essentially this is the ability
to say I'm gonna have a date a class an
object type that supports some other
data type in it so a very classical
example is a list of T I don't care what
T is I don't care if it's a list of
integers I don't care if it's a list of
strings I want to support just a generic
list of things and I don't really I'm
not gonna do anything with those things
but otherwise just manage a whole lot of
them right so you you know this syntax
is probably similar if you're like in
c-sharp or Java it's gonna be angle
brackets but you get the idea this is
just straight-up generics okay that's
parametric polymorphism so in this
example we have we're modeling vehicles
and at the top we have an interface or a
trait called the thing we have a vehicle
car G motorcycle and randomly thrown in
a vegetable and so you can kind of see
how those all derive from each other and
then we're gonna have a class that
represents parking it's going to take a
type into it we don't know what type but
it's going to take a type now if I
create a parking that expects a
motorcycle type then I have to pass in a
motorcycle to that if I try to pass in a
car it's not going to compile because
that is a instance that is expecting the
type motorcycle all right but I can
change my example and I can say parking
takes a car and I can pass in a jeep
because a jeep is a car according to the
type hierarchy I can use type inference
so I'm not even gonna specify a type
here I'm gonna pass in two jeeps and the
compiler the type system is going to
figure out I'm talking about a Jeep
alright now what do you think is gonna
happen if I put take this exact same
function I put two different types in
there let's take a Jeep and a motorcycle
what's gonna happen at that point okay
yes so essentially it's gonna go to the
nearest common type of vehicle alright
so if I passing car motorcycle the
nearest common type between those is
going to be the vehicle interface now
this is something you might not have
seen before which is bounds checking
there's two different type upper and
lower bounds there is another theory use
throw that out there to sound smart but
essentially order theory says a partial
order is a binary relation over a set
piece so an a is a in that little symbol
there a less than equal to typically B
we say that a is related to B but does
not imply B is related to a the only
reason I bring this up is because the
syntax that you see and most the
functional languages comes from this
definition all right you'll see an arrow
with usually a colon or equal so in this
example look at what we've done to
parking we say parking can take an A as
long as it is bounded by vehicle so in
other words I can pass in a Jeep because
a Jeep is a vehicle I cannot pass in a
vegetable because that's not in the
lineage of the vehicle all right so I've
put it what's called an upper bound on
that type and you can get more
sophisticated where you can have upper
and lower bounds so I can say an a where
it's between a Jeep and a vehicle any
questions here
all right existential types this is
whenever you need parameterised types
but you don't really care what it is so
the syntax you can use is an underscore
so in my list above I have a list of T
but you'll notice in my implementation I
don't use T at all it's it's irrelevant
what that is so I can just say
underscore and it just means whatever
just that's not important it's just a
generic type as long as it's using
parametric polymorphism move on all
right so that's existential types not a
whole lot to say there about those
alright for this I'm gonna switch over
to some code how many of you before have
worked with type variants oh great ok
cool
so let's look at this code for a minute
I have a series of types here I got a
person grandparents a parent child
grandchild alright I tried to keep that
natural from kind of a top bottom
lineage right to make it clear so I'm
gonna
get my cheat sheet
actually I just realized I'm kind of
coming close to time so I'm gonna cheat
and we're just going to show the
solution here so I really want to get to
the next one the idea of the variance is
that we want to control what can be what
types in a range of types are available
for sub classing so when I say two types
are variant to each other that means the
two types are are equal so a list of
string is compatible with another list
of string if I have a list of string
compared to a list of integer those are
called invariants there are two
different types technically but it would
be really nice if I can define a
function or a class that takes a list of
a type and any of its derivatives so I
might say I want to create a type that
would take a list of people and anything
else that is considered a person I
should be able to accept that too that
is called covariance so that means that
I am saying these all these subtypes
will be treated as instances of all of
the higher types as well so we can see
that here so in this case I have denoted
that this is covariance and that's done
in Scala by using a little plus I start
out with a function that I say okay it's
going to take a box of a person and then
I can pass in any instance that is a
subtype of person and it will compile so
person child grandchild grandparents all
right now look in this example I'm going
to go one more I'm going to define
another function though that says it's
going to be at the parent level so I can
pass in a child and a grandchild but
when I try to pass in grandparent that
doesn't work because that is in a
different spot in the type hierarchy
covariance is usually pretty
straightforward to understand it's when
we talk about contravariance
things get a little bit more muggy so
real quickly actually let me split my
screen so we can see our types at the
same time okay look at this guy
down here when I say contravariance all
I'm really saying is is it's going the
other direction I'm gonna say I'm gonna
accept the type that is higher up the
hierarchy but not lower that's really
what I'm saying when I say contravariant
it's the other way around so I might
take something that's a parent I can
take a grandparent I can take a person
but I can't take a grandchild okay does
anybody want to say why contravariance
is important you want to take a swing at
that one
no man Dylan go for it yeah okay so I'm
gonna apologize for this slide right now
this is a terrible slide but I'm gonna
try alright this is a this is one of the
de-facto reasons why you need
contravariance when you're designing a
functional programming language or I'm
sorry not functional just a programming
language is the this is in Scala that's
the definition of a function of one
parameter so in the comment and the
standard library that's what it looks
like you have P and a contravariant
position an R which is the result in a
covariant position and so this is the
definition of a functor and a to a b and
what we're saying is that we can take in
AP and any of its any type that is up
the type hierarchy so anything that's
less specialized we can accept as an
input as an output we can return
anything that is more specialized what
we're really saying is is that if we're
going to subclass that function the
inputs can only have fewer requirements
you can't pass something in it's gonna
have more requirements but the outputs
must at least be as specialized
because the caller expects those to be
available all right so in other words
I'm not gonna return something from a
function that has fewer things and what
I expected out anyway I'm not going to
go into that if you're interested in
learning more about
variance I'm going to share these slides
afterwards and there's a link at the
bottom that goes into some really nice
details about that ok this is what I
really wanted to get to and I've put
myself in a wall because I only give
myself about 15 minutes to do it but
type classes these to me are really
exciting all right how many of you have
used type classes before Scott yeah ok
if you're in Haskell that's all you got
if you're in Scala it's it's kind of
weird okay
type classes are you well actually let's
just let's just dive in what are the
disadvantages of object-oriented
inheritance help me out here letters
what are some problems with inheritance
it's unclear how the inheritance tree
should look do you mean like you know
that like what abstraction you should
take yes yeah designing abstractions
through inheritance is really hard to
get right it's easy to start dropping
inheritance in and somebody else'll it
comes the way and says oh I need
something hey kind of looks like this
super type I'm just gonna inherit from
it and then before long you get like
this this just mess of inheritance and
everything's at the wrong abstraction
oh man yeah multiple inheritance where
you get like all kinds of diamond-shaped
patterns or circular things can really
make it hard like if you have like a
diamond pattern in your inheritance and
both of them defined the same base like
member like which one does it come out
of which one does it call yeah any
others
yeah violates encapsulation because now
you've got multiple classes that are
going to borrow the same members in a
sense you've tightly coupled those so
modifying them can become harder
especially when you start using that all
through your code base and then you've
got to modify your type higher your
inheritance hierarchy you get into
problems real fast I hate reading code
that uses inheritance oh I hate it hate
it hate it it's great if you're reading
like writing it but then once you need
like you're in something it's like where
did this member come from and you're
looking through files and you know if
you're using an IDE that's one thing
these kind of help I like using them
don't get a lot of help so now I'm
looking through files and I'm frustrated
okay reuse abuse we talked about that we
are really bad at following dry
correctly okay and also if you're using
a library that gives you types you can't
do anything with that library right you
can't you can't add inheritance to
something that you don't own in your
codebase and that is where we're gonna
get into type classes being incredibly
important okay so commonly we hear of a
composition is the solution to
inheritance use composition instead of
inheritance where possible there's a
couple other things but what about
another way all right what if we wanted
to add behavior to types we don't own
that's pretty cool what if we want to a
selectively apply behavior in different
scopes of our code base hmm yeah people
are getting excited right now
I know I can't hear it salsa but I know
they are flipping out right now okay
what if we wanted to apply lawful
behaviors to our abstractions
and I'm excited I just really excited
dizzy
this just got even better all right he
probably is there he's I meet up he saw
this I know he's sitting there Darren's
there in high five on them right now
yeah tight glasses these guys are pretty
cool the idea of the type class is we're
gonna separate behavior from data so
when you're coming from a classical
object-oriented background you're going
to put the two together a lot of times
you'll have objects and those objects
are going to have methods right so the
methods go with the objects there is a
totally different paradigm though where
we're gonna separate out behavior from
objects completely so we're gonna have
the data type a structure we're not
going to apply any methods to that
that's going to be defined separately
all right
now some might say well I can do that
with interfaces or traits but you can't
really do anything though about those
data types you don't own all right
that's still a problem so here's what a
type class does oh wait a minute okay
there's a slide I meant to have in there
type classes kind of turned the idea on
its head of the ownership of functions
all right what type classes we're going
to be behaviors first and then the data
comes second whereas an object-oriented
programming it's the other way around
the objects come first the behaviors
come with okay so here are the elements
of a type class now in Scala this is a
little bit awkward
Haskell this is just how you do it right
you know you use type classes all the
time in Haskell but you have the
behavior that you want so this is
commonly comes down to a trait or an
interface you have instances that for
each of the data types that you want to
apply that behavior to so if I'm going
to be working with people and when apply
behavior to a person type I'm gonna have
to have a concrete type for that integer
strings those are going to have their
specialized implementations and then I
need some sort of interface that I
exposed to my users through my ap
so here's what this looks like the
behaviors at the top and then you're
gonna have your your function that
requires that type with a behavior so
I'm going to write a function that says
you can pass in anything to me as long
as it has the behavior that I expect all
right and so then it's up to you to just
provide those behaviors for whatever
type so how is this different than
interfaces all right first of all I get
a compiler error if I try to pass in a
type into my function that does not have
that behavior come with it I can import
those behaviors into different scopes so
I can't say in this part of my code I'm
going to bring in these behaviors from
this you know this list of behaviors
over here just for this area doesn't
have to be holistic through the code
base I can also provide behaviors for
types I don't own so if I'm using a
really sweet you know type that I Brer E
I get from somebody I can apply I can
create behaviors on how it would
interact in my own code base and then
suddenly I can now use that type with
other behavior libraries out there and
it's really easy to drop in new things
okay I already said this essentially
we're flipping instead of thinking about
classes caring behaviors we have
templates of behaviors and then we're
bringing along interpretations for
different types so here's an example in
Scala this is awkward and Scala
unfortunately this is not a first class
citizen in Scala it's an idiomatic
pattern if you're in Haskell is built
into the language but you can kind of
get the idea though we have a sealed
trade at the top okay we're gonna
represent adjacent type alright and then
we have different Jason things we're
gonna have a JSON object a JSON string
adjacent number and then jason null all
of these extend from jason all right so
that's just defining my types now the
json writer that's the behave
here that I want to create I want to be
able to take in a thing
okay type a and produce adjacent from
its anything I want to produce a Jason
alright that's the behavior I want a to
Jason so the next step I got to do is I
have to define the implementation of
that behavior for the types I care about
so I'm going to do it for two different
types I'm going to do this for Strings
and I'm going to do this for a person
type so the string type essentially says
okay we're gonna override the right
method we're going to convert that to a
Jas string and return that out so it
takes a string as the inputs and then
it's going to return a JSON string out
for the person type which I've defined
above it's going to take in a person and
then this is going to create a Jas
object with the attributes broken out
the key value pairs now this is where it
gets great because now I can define a
function that says to Jason and what I'm
doing there is I'm saying with that
implicit I'm saying whatever a is there
has to be a jason writer for type a in
scope so in other words that behavior
has to be in presence has to be present
in scope to work and so down at the
bottom is what i finally gets I'm gonna
say Jason - Jason I can pass in a person
and now I'm going to get out adjacent
object I can pass in a string and now
I'm gonna get adjacent object out of it
where you really see this is libraries
like if you're in the Scala ecosystem
you see this with Scala Z or the cats
library those are just type class
libraries and what they are is they're
behaviors for category theory and so you
get all the semi-group 'el the functor
the folding and kind of morphic
capabilities you get monoids and monads
you have all those lawful behaviors to
find in scala z and cats and then you
get a whole bunch of implementations of
those behaviors so you just drop it into
your project and
all of your types can now work with
lawful behavior okay so pretty cool I'm
gonna skip this yeah high school does it
really well Scala and could use some
work we're not gonna get to higher kind
of types and that's it